Candid Truth.
What is up everybody? Thank you for
joining us at Candid Truth. We're going
to talk about the truth and we're going
to get candid with it. I just heard the
news yesterday that the new pope has
been elected. This is history making the
first United States pope to be elected.
Now, why is that so profound or
prophetic? Because it is prophetic.
There have been people for hundreds of
years now who have predicted that
America is the second beast of
revelation that rises out of the earth
and will join and unite with the first
beast of revelation which is papal Rome
and we are seeing it more than ever.
There's already been signs along the way
but this is insane. So check this out.
This has made the news. It says history
made with election of first American
pope. So people have been waiting for
America, the the superpower of the
world, to unite and join forces with the
papacy, who was the the world ruler,
right? They were killing Christians,
burning them at the stake. If they had
the the Bible in their own translation,
or if they basically rejected the pope,
they would be burned at the stake. That
was the papal system. It was a religion
forced by law. And we know prophetically
that's going to come about again that
there's going to be a one world religion
enforced upon the whole world by law.
But let's talk about Protestantism
because if you are not a Catholic by
definition you are a Protestant because
that's where the word comes from. So a
lot of us we we know ourselves as
Christian or evangelical. And if you if
you ask a Catholic are you a Christian?
They will say I'm Catholic. They'll
correct you. They won't say they're a
Christian. They say I am Catholic. Why?
Because Catholicism is not Christianity.
And so if you are a Christian who is not
a Catholic, you are by definition a
Protestant. Where does that word come
from? Christians are called Protestants
because of the Protestant
Reformation. A 16th century movement
that initiated a split from the Catholic
Church. The term Protestant originated
when groups disagreed with certain
practices and doctrines of the Catholic
Church and protested against them. So
that word protest is where we get the
word Protestant. We are protesting the
Catholic Church. That Babylon system
that is not Christian that was forcing
their beliefs upon the world and burn
you at the stake if you have the Bible
in your own language. Remember the
Catholic Church said we are the only
ones that can understand the Bible. The
Bible cannot be interp or cannot be
translated outside of Latin and you
could only hear the word of God through
the pope or through the priest who could
understand Latin and they give you the
word of God quote unquote. Um it says
the protest, what is the protest about?
In 1529, German princes issued a formal
protest against the diet of spire, a
council that had voted to enforce the
edict, the edict of worms, which would
have subjected Luther's followers to
poverty forfeite. This protest led to
the term Protestant being applied to
those who disagreed with the Catholic
Church's decisions and practices
according to the encyclopedia of
Bratannica. Martin Luther, he was a
Catholic monk. I mean, fully dedicated
Catholic monk. And when he started going
down into the basement and reading a
Bible that was chained to the wall, he
was like, "Wait a minute. Uh, the gospel
is actually for all people. We have a
personal relationship with Jesus Christ.
It's not about rights and rituals and
all these things that the Catholic
Church are saying, Hail Marys and beat
yourself and all this stuff and
confessing to a a priest. It's about a
personal relationship with Jesus Christ.
So he came up with 95 thesis and he
nailed them. He boldly went up to the
door of the Catholic Church and nailed
these things into the door and said, "I
want to have a debate with you, a public
debate out here." And we're going to
talk about how this system is corrupt.
So if you didn't know about that, that's
where all this started. The protest, the
Protestant Reformation. CBS News says
new pope chooses Leo as his papal name.
Here's why pontiffs change their names
and what they mean. So this guy's name
is not Leo. Ironically, I think his name
is Francis. But he chose his name. Just
like Pope Francis chose his name, this
pope chose Leo. Why? Because
he's using the name of a a former pope.
And this is what it says. When Martin
Luther started his protest in 1517, the
pope was Leo I 10th, he would later
formally excommunicate Luther in 1521.
So, ironically, when the Protestant
movement formed, when this
identification of who the beast system
was, because Martin Luther, we're going
to look at some quotes, Martin Luther
identified the Catholic Church system as
the Antichrist beast system of
Revelation. And when that happened, when
the protest was formed, ironically, the
pope was Pope Leo I 10th. Now we have
Pope Leo I 14th. I don't think that's a
coincidence that all this stuff is
happening right now. We have Trump being
put in office with this whole project
2025 thing that says that he can enact
any religious law he wants to. They're
trying to give him a third term and
making him look like Caesar. They're
calling him Constantine who enacted
religious laws and forcing people to
worship on Sunday, the venerable day of
the sun. He made a a a image or a video
as him as a golden idol, a golden image
just like Nebuchadnezzar forcing all the
world to bow down at his image. And then
he made an AI image of him as the pope.
Why all this connection? Why is Trump
connecting himself to Babylon, to
Catholicism, to the papal Rome system?
In 1 Peter 5'8, it says, "Be sober, be
vigilant, because your adversary, the
devil, as a roaring lion, walketh about
seeking whom he may devour." This might
be a stretch. I'll give you that. But I
think it's ironic that this pope chose
the name Leo. When you look at
astrology, Leo is the lion. And we see
in prophecy that in the last days, if
you read the verse before this, it talks
about in the last days, how we need to
be sober and be vigilant because Satan's
like a roaring lion out here seeking
whom he can devour. You know, history's
been changed and taught to us in these
indoctrination systems. We hear like the
whole Thanksgiving story, Christopher
Columbus, and he made friends with the
Native Americans and they had a a dinner
together and that's how we got America,
right? Well, actually the truth is more
sinister than that. America was founded
by Protestants fleeing papal and state
religious tyranny. The blood of martyrs
soaked the soil of Europe because they
rejected the pope's authority, refused
to attend Catholic mass or owned a
Bible. They were killed for owning a
Bible by a quote unquote Christian
system. They came to America to worship
God freely, not under the dictates of
Rome or kings, but according to
scripture and conscience. So that's the
whole point. We want to have freedom of
religion, which is what the first
amendment in the constitution says.
Congress shall make no law respecting an
establishment of religion or prohibiting
the free exercise thereof. So you can't
make a law against my religion and you
can't make a law forcing religion. This
is why we have separation separation of
church and state. Now, atheists have
taken that and run with it and say, "Oh,
you you're not allowed to have a a cross
or a ten commandments because this is
city property." And maybe we shouldn't.
Maybe we should keep that for private
property. But the whole purpose of
separation of church and state was to
keep the state, the government, out of
your religion to not be able to enforce
you to worship a certain way or to say
that you cannot worship a certain way.
And I believe that we should have
separation of church and state unlike
Trump. Listen to what he says. And you
know they work right out of the White
House. They've never done that. That's
never been done before. No other
president allowed that. I think you know
they say
separation they say separation between
church and state. They told me I said
all right let's forget about that for
one time. We said really the separation
I don't know is that a good thing or a
bad thing? I'm not sure. But whether
there's separation or not, you guys are
in the White House where you should be
and you're representing our country and
we're bringing religion back to our
country and uh it's a big deal. Uh yeah,
I'd say it is a big deal. He just said,
"Let's forget about separation of church
and state. We're bringing religion back
to our country." Now, I want you to
notice something about Trump's cabinet
here because this is a a Catholic
website that says the Trump
administration more Catholic than you
know. Right here, Catholic vote. This
was shared on Twitter or X. And it says
Donald Trump has nominated 12 Catholics
to prominent positions in his
administration, making his cabinet one
of the most Catholic dominated in
American history. Is it any coincidence
that we get Trump? They're saying
project 2025, you can write any
religious law you want to. He has the
most Catholics on his cabinet than any
other. Pope Francis dies and gets
replaced by the first ever American
pope. We are about to see some huge
changes. Things are about to rapidly
progress prophetically. Donald Trump,
his official ex post here says,
"Congratulations to Cardinal Robert
Francis, that's his birth name, who was
just named Pope. It is such an honor to
realize that he is the first American
pope." Wait, is such an honor? Why are
we honored by something that's happening
over in Vatican City, Rome? What has
that got to do with us? Well, when you
look into this, you'll see that every
world leader has to fly over there and
go make deals with the Pope and shake
his hand and bow to him and all that.
Trump did it. Obama did it. Bush did it.
Every president has gone over there and
made deals with the Pope because he's
the one in power and Satan's ultimately
in power over him. So, he's saying um
that it's such an honor to realize that
he is the first American pope. What
excitement and what a great honor for
our country. Why? What does our country
have to do with Vatican Rome? Even if
it's an American pope, who cares? So
what? He was born on uh Chicago soil,
but now he's the pope. So why is that an
honor to America? Tell me. I look
forward to meeting Pope Leo. It will be
a very meaningful moment. I bet it will.
Very meaningful from Donald Trump. So we
see here that there the protest is over.
We are supposed to be Protestants
forever. We're supposed to continue to
protest this Antichrist beast system
which Revelation talks about. But we see
here Billy Graham hanging out with the
pope. We see Rick Warren hanging out
with the pope. Kenneth Copelan who
actually said that the protest is over
and he a Catholic priest got up on stage
and said, "Well, I guess we're all
Catholic now." And Kenneth Copelan's
whole crowd cheered and with joy. And
here we see Francis Chan, if you don't
know who he is, he's all about love
movement and all this stuff. And on
stage he had multiple Catholic priests
come and pray over him. Why? Why are we
uniting ourselves with the antichrist
beast system? Because it's all under the
guise of coexist and and love and unity
and we need to come together. And the
Bible says when they say peace and
safety, sudden destruction will come
upon them. That's what we are seeing
here today. So this brings me to blue
laws because are there any laws in
America that enforce religion in any
kind of way? We just looked at the first
amendment that says that government
shall make no law enforcing religion or
restricting religion. So why do we have
something called blue laws? It says blue
laws are regulations that restrict or
prohibit certain activities often on
Sundays with the intent to promote a day
of rest or religious observance. They
are also known as Sunday laws, Sunday
trade laws or uniform days of rest laws.
So it does sound good. It sounds like a
good thing. Like hey, there should be a
day that nobody can force you to work
because everybody needs a break, right?
Everybody needs a rest. And the idea
comes from the seventh day Sabbath that
God blessed and hallowed at on the
seventh day of creation where he said
six days you shall work and one you
shall rest. And even science has backed
this up that we cannot work more than
six days and survive. Uh there's been
certain Soviet countries that tried to
put 10 days in their calendar and they
had to go back to seven. They had to go
back to the original creation calendar
because man, the human body is not meant
to work more than six days a week. But
God blessed and hallowed the seventh
day, Sabbath, not Sunday for one, and it
should never be enforced by man. This is
where we're crossing lines. The we're
blurring the lines of church and state
again. We're supposed to keep them
separate. Separation of church and
state. What is the purpose? Blue laws
were originally intended to enforce,
that's a word, enforce a day of rest,
and promote religious observances,
especially on Sundays, which are
considered the Sabbath in Christianity.
But that's not true. That happened
because of Roman Roman Emperor
Constantine. He was the one that pushed
the first Sunday law and said, "If you
are caught Judaizing or keeping the
Sabbath, you will be killed, but you
must keep the venerable day of the sun."
Look the stuff up. Constantine enforced
keeping the venerable day of the sun. It
was the first Sunday
law. Constitutional challenges. Now,
here's some challenges because how can
we enforce a religious law? Well, it
says blue laws have been challenged in
courts with some ar with some arguing
they violate the first amendment's
establishment clause by promoting
religious observance. It does seem like
that, right? But here's what it says.
Modern application. While some blue laws
have been relaxed or repealed due to
changing societal norms, they still
exist in many states, particularly in
the realm of alcohol sales. So in modern
times what they have said now is well
they're actually constitutional because
they promote health and they promote
health for the climate and health and
well-being because of COVID. When COVID
happened they had these lockdowns and
when the lockdowns were happening they
said we've actually seen this help
climate change. This is all a huge
agenda to push the future one world
religion and the enforcement of Sunday
observance worshiping the venerable day
of the sun is coming and all these
little things have just been scops along
the way to condition us to get ready for
the Sunday law. They're telling us that
there's climate change and there's all
these pandemics and you know what to for
the embedment of humanity we need to
just rest on Sunday. This has been an
agenda for a long time. When you read
the book of Revelation, there's two
beasts. The first beast rises out of the
waters, which represents many peoples
and nations and multitudes and tongues.
And when you really dig into it, it is
no doubt the only system that fits. It
is the papal Rome system. It has seven
heads. The Bible says the seven heads
are seven mountains or seven hills. You
can do a Google search right now. What
is the city of seven hills? Rome. It
says that there's a harlot, which would
be a corrupt church because a woman
represents a church in the Bible. This
harlot church is riding on the beast,
which is a kingdom with seven heads,
which are seven hills. And this corrupt
church, harlot, is dressed in purple and
scarlet and decked with gold and
precious stones. Google
this purple, scarlet, gold church. one
church will show up. It's Vatican. Now,
that's the first beast. What is this
second beast? Well, we know that this
second beast is rising during the fall
of the first beast. The first beast had
a fatal wound back a long time ago.
There was this general Berier. He e he
ripped the pope off the throne. He e he
put him in exile and the pope died in
exile. That was the fatal head wound
that this beast suffered. But it says
that this beast will resurrect from that
fatal head wound. Now, as that was as
that head wound was going down in the
1700s, the late 1700s, it says, "I saw
another beast rising up." What other
kingdom? What other beast kingdom was
rising in the late
1700s? It was rising out of the earth,
which represents a not so populated
area. If the waters represent many
peoples, then the dry earth represents a
not so populated area. This was America.
It rose up in the late 1700s in a in a
area that only had some Native Americans
there. And it has two horns like a lamb.
What does a lamb represent in the Bible?
Christ. This is a Christian nation. It
has a facade of being a Christian
nation, but it speaks as a dragon. How
does a nation speak? Through its laws.
And so we pretend to be this Christian
nation, but we are making laws that are
sending us back to paple Rome that are
speaking like a dragon or like Satan or
like Rome. This is happening right
before our very eyes. Revelation
13:11-15 says, "And I beheld another
beast coming up out of the earth, and he
had two horns like a lamb, and he spake
as a dragon, and he exercised all the
power of the first beast, which was
Rome, before him. And he caused all the
earth, or he caused the earth, and them
which dwell in the earth to worship the
first beast, Rome, whose deadly wound
was healed. and he doeth great wonders,
so that he maketh fire come down from
heaven on the earth in the sight of men,
and he deceive them which dwell on the
earth by the means of those miracles. So
this beast is going to deceive the world
through miracles which had power to do
in the sight of the beast, saying to
them that dwell on the earth, that they
should make an image to the beast, which
had the wound by a sword, and did live.
And he had power to give life unto the
image of the beast, that the image of
the beast should both speak and cause
that as many as would not worship the
image of the beast should be killed.
Now, that was a mouthful. That was a
lot. But basically, what we have here is
this second beast. That's America. And
he is saying all the world must worship
the first beast. And we're going to make
an image unto the beast. And what is the
beast? The beast is papal Rome, this
church state system. So, if we're going
to make an exact mirror image, we're
making a new system of worship that's
enforced upon the world and punishable
by death. That's the new image of the
beast. That's the coexist one world
religion that's coming very soon. And it
says, "Whoever doesn't worship this
system will be killed." That's what it's
saying. Now, check this out because this
is nothing new. Little seeds along the
way have been planted over the years.
Pope Francis even had a commercial
saying this.
[Music]
Allah
multitudes foreign.
[Music]
very interesting, right? He just said
like we all worship the same God. You
know, there's there's many different
ways of God and for you it might be
Buddha, for you it's Allah, and for you
it's Jesus, but it's all the same God.
Let's just coexist. Kumbaya. Let's all
unite together. And it's going to look
so good that it's going to deceive
millions of well-meaning Christians
because it looks like peace and unity
and coexist and love. Ultimately, it
looks like love when you accept and you
have tolerance of other people. And on
the surface, that's how it looks to our
flesh. It looks good. But it is
compromising the word of God. It
compromises the truth. And if you are a
Christian, then you are supposed to be
following what the Bible and the Bible
alone says. And if the Bible says that
this very thing is going to happen and
we see it happening, we can't get caught
up in our emotions and feelings and say,
you know what, this is it. This is this
has to be of God because it feels so
good. It feels like love. Well, guess
what? Satan is masquerading as an angel
of light. When you talk to newagers,
they believe in love. They feel love.
They practice yoga and and condundalini
and they feel euphoria and love and all
these things and they're some of the
nicest people that you'll ever meet. But
it's not of God. If you believe that,
then you are compromising and you're not
a Christian. You're not a Bible believer
because the Bible cuts like a two-edged
sword. And that's what's going to happen
in the last days. Brother will turn
against brother and father will turn
against son and households are going to
be divided because we're going to be
saying, "No, this is the truth. The word
of God says this is truth and nothing
else can be truth. The heart is
deceitful above all things and
desperately wicked. Who can know it? We
cannot fall for our feelings and
emotions. So this coexist movement is
coming. Seems like it's already here,
but it's not enforced by law yet. That's
what we're waiting on. This is not a new
idea. These are from the the reformers.
The Protestant Reformation. Martin
Luther said, "We here are of the
conviction that the papacy is the seat
of the true and real antichrist." Now,
Martin Luther only lived from 1483 to
1546. So during that time period, he
said the papal system is the true and
real antichrist. He said, "I know that
the pope is the antichrist and that his
throne is that of Satan himself." This
is not a new idea. This has been
predicted for so long. John Calvin, he
was a reformation and the founder of the
Calvin church, Calvinism. And he said,
"Some persons think us too severe and
sensorious when we call the Roman
pontiff Antichrist, but those who are of
this opinion do not consider that they
bring the same charge of presumption
against Paul himself." I shall briefly
show that Paul's words in 2
Thessalonians 2 are not capable of any
other interpretation than that which
applies them to the papacy. These are
bold words right here. Thomas Cranmer,
he was an archbishop and an English
reformer and he said, "Whereof it
followeth Rome to be the seat of
Antichrist and the pope to be very
Antichrist himself." I could prove the
same by many other scriptures, old
writers, and strong reasons. These
people knew without a shadow of a doubt
the antichrist system is the
papacy. John Knox, he was a Scottish
reformer. He said, "Yay, we doubt not to
prove the kingdom of the pope to be the
kingdom and power of
antichrist." And Roger Williams, he was
a Baptist minister. So, this isn't one
denomination. This is all the way across
the board. He was the founder of Rhode
Island. He said, "The pretended vicer of
Christ," because that's what the pope
says, that they are the substitute
replacement of Christ, meaning
Antichrist. The pretended vicor of
Christ on earth, who sits as God over
the temple of God, exalting himself not
only above all that is called God, but
over the souls and consciences of all
his vassels. Yay, over the spirit of
Christ. He is indeed the real antichrist
and his chariot is death and hell
follows. And Cotton Mathther, a Puritan
minister in New England said, "The
oracles of God foretold the rising of an
antichrist in the Christian church." In
the Christian church. And in the pope of
Rome, all the characteristics of the
antichrist are so marvelously answered
that if anyone if any who reads the
scriptures do not see it, there is a
marvelous blindness upon them. I agree
with these statements 100%. And these
people knew if you don't see it, you
have been blinded by the god of this
world, which is Satan. Satan's doing
everything he can to make you not
believe this by creating ideas like
futurism where everything happens way
far in the future. It couldn't have been
the papacy because that was in the past.
And then there's the opposite extreme of
predtoism like oh even Christ has
already returned and it was a spiritual
return and everything of revelation has
already happened. Those are the far
extremes. We got to find balance right
here in the middle with the
historist view which means we are seeing
prophecy play out over the years right
in front of our eyes and right now it's
more plain than
ever. The
Westminster confession of faith uh
reformed Presbyterian statement said,
"There is no other head of the church
but the Lord Jesus Christ, nor can the
Pope of Rome in any sense be head
thereof, but is that Antichrist, that
man of sin and son of predition that
exalted himself in the church against
Christ and all that is called God."
These are clear. And there is a book
called The Great Controversy written in
1858. And this book has church history
and scripture and even prophetic visions
that point to what is coming in our
future. And we are seeing it happen
right now. This was written in the
1800s. And it says, "Protestants of the
United States will be foremost in
stretching their hands across the gulf
to grasp the hand of spiritualism. They
will reach over the abyss to clasp hands
with the Roman power. This country will
follow in the steps of Rome and
trampling on the rights of conscience.
So if your conscience says I have to
obey the word of God, I have to follow
the ten commandments. I have to keep the
seventh day Sabbath because that's what
the Bible says. And if you force me to
keep anything else that goes against my
conscience, my beliefs, you will be
persecuted and killed in this new system
that's coming.
and it's a merging of America and Rome.
And we're seeing it today. Here's
another quote from that book. When the
leading churches of the United States,
uniting upon such points of doctrine as
are held by them in common, shall
influence the state to enforce their
decrees and to s sustain their
institutions, then Protestant America
will have formed an image of the Roman
hierarchy. Now, that's what we're
talking about. America is going to form
an image of the beast, which is papal
Rome. That is very soon. That is right
around the corner. We literally now have
an American pope, a president with the
most Catholics on his board of anyone in
history. And he's saying, "Let's
separate church and state. Let's do away
with that. We're bringing religion back
to America." And all the world cheers
and claps because it's the biggest
deception in human history. This is the
test of salvation. If you fall for this
system, you will lose salvation. If you
take the mark in the head, it means that
you believe the system and you worship
willfully. But if you take it in the
hand, it means that you do not believe
the system, but you will do it. You'll
obey it just to preserve your life or
the life of your family and you will
receive the mark in your hand. We must
be like Shadrach, Meshach, and Abedneo.
I refuse to bow to the image. I don't
believe it. And I won't even simply bow
my body. Throw me into the fire because
heaven will be cheap enough. When we get
there, nothing in this world will be
worth missing out on eternal life.
Nothing. What profits a man to gain the
whole world and lose his very soul?
There are three books that I recommend.
National Sunday Law, The Great
Controversy, and Ten Commandments Twice
Removed. You can get these books for
very cheap. You can get them on PDF for
free. If you reach out to me, I'll mail
you some for free if I have some while
supplies last. I want you to get this
information because this is vital. These
things are coming true right before our
very eyes. And it's really just
mind-blowing. I can't believe that it's
happening the way it is right now. If
this was eye- openening to you, please
give it a thumbs up. Share this with
your family and friends because this
stuff is happening rapidly. It's going
to happen quicker than you can even
imagine. And it's going to take us like
an overwhelming surprise. Like we are
not going to be expecting this because a
lot of churches aren't even teaching
this at all. They're teaching that we
need to just come together and and uh
unite on the fact that we all believe in
Jesus Christ. Doesn't matter if you're
Catholic or Protestant or Calvin or
whatever you are. Let's just unite and
coexist and kumbaya and but when they
say peace and safety, sudden destruction
will come upon them. If you'd like to
support this ministry, you can do so by
going to candidtruth.org. We have
multiple ways to give there. We cannot
do this without you. We are fully
donation supported ministry. And if you
have donated to this ministry, we thank
you so much. We are still able to do
this because of you. And if you guys
would like to get t-shirts, we actually
have a shop on our website. We got some
cool scripture shirts. We got some cool
shirts that just say things like, "Be
cool. Use your brain." Because there is
an agenda to dumb us down, to keep us
from thinking, because dumb people are
easier to control. Satan's trying to
deceive the entire world. And now more
than ever, we need to be vigilant, be
sober, because Satan's out there like a
roaring lion. We love you. We thank you.
We'll see you next time on Can of Truth.